la situation en aquitaine maintenant là
bas les rafales ont atteint jusqu'à 180
km/heure ravageant tout sur leur passage
dans cette région aussi là des milliers
de foyers sont privés d'électricité de
nombreuses routes restent interdites à
la circulation
natalie cole la tempête était annoncé
sur l'aquitaine mais personne ne
s'attendait à une telle violence
dès 20 heures hier un mélange de pluie
et de sable balle et l'a jetée
d'arcachon rapidement l'eau envahit la
ville
ces intempéries ont fait trois morts et
des dizaines de blessés dans la région
ici le vent va atteindre 180 km/heure
jamais on n'a jamais eu une erreur comme
ça jamais jamais ça fait dix ans que le
mahler était installée ici on n'a jamais
eu autant de régal a bordeaux vers 22h
dans coup la garonne sort de son lit
très vite les berges sentiment d sur
plusieurs dizaines de kilomètres dans le
centre ville en quelques minutes 300
arbres sont arrachés des pans entiers de
murs s'effondrent des toitures s'envole
arrachée avec la forme des équipes télé
son projet sur une voiture
aujourd'hui dans tous les départements
de la gironde les dégâts sont
considérables des bâtiments fissurés
menace de s'effondrer des monuments
comme la cathédrale pey-berland en
l'église saint michel sont gravement
endommagée ce soir plusieurs communes le
long de la garonne sont encore inondées
j'ai plein d'amis symptômes et qui
mangeait tous mes animaux qui y voit
j'ai beaucoup d'animaux de mort et tout
ça s'est réalisé 21 quoi plusieurs
dizaines de personnes ont dû être
évacuées dans le nord de la gironde
suite à la rupture d'une digue ce soir
une centaine de communes restent privées
d'eau potable dans le département